well for the time being the biggest
threat to your second Amendment rights
guaranteed to your ancestors over 200
years ago isn't actually lawmakers or
kids from parkland you see in cable
television it could be big corporations
last month Citigroup demanded that all
its business partners restrict gun sales
now in the state of New York the state
comptroller Thomas DiNapoli has just
sent a letter to Visa Wells Fargo Bank
of America and six other financial
companies saying they ought to explore
the possibility of blocking credit card
users from buying guns ammunition or
firearms related accessories meanwhile
some towns are acting as well Deerfield
Illinois north of Chicago has just
passed a ban on so-called assault
weapons every person in the town is
required to give up them and those who
don't will be fined $1000 a day mark
Stein is an author and columnist and
joins us tonight
so mark I can't mean both these stories
are sort of a peace and they're both
interesting but the second one first if
you were to as Deerfield has banned the
possession of weapons that are currently
held by law-abiding people what would
that look like wouldn't at some point
you have to go door-to-door wouldn't you
yeah I think you do and I would be
surprised even in the most liberal
jurisdiction if you can make the case
that $1000 a day fine bears any relation
to the offense I don't think that will
stand up if anybody's minded to contest
that fine and I would advise people to
contest it too because I think that's
absolute that is absolutely outrageous
and is intended basically to intimidate
people into giving up something which
the day before yesterday was entirely
lawful for them to have ultimately all
of these conversations come down to
force you're gonna have to start making
people do things law-abiding people
American citizens things they don't want
to do and a lot of the pressure to
control seems to be coming from
corporate America which is hard for some
conservatives get their heads around
because they think well they're on our
side we're on their side we're for
capitalism but things have changed it
seems like well I think that's what's
interesting about the New York proposal
if you want to get rid of guns if you
want to curtail access to guns do you do
as John Paul Stevens the the former
Supreme Court honcho suggests and
repealed the Second Amendment that's
never gonna happen
so instead do you get corporations and
lean on them to in effect do an end run
round the Constitution and if you look
at what's happened with the way
corporations for example are quite happy
to collude in restricting freedom of
expression we've seen over the last year
paypal and other merchant processors
quite happy to eliminate customers and
ideological grounds I think it's very
the moment it's technically difficult I
mean if you go into Walmart and use your
MasterCard they can't technically tell
whether you're buying a couple of
Twinkies and a blueberry muffin or a
firearm but once they can get past that
hurdle so that a bell goes off and your
normal credit card won't work when you
buy a firearm they will have gone a long
way to denormalize gun ownership and
Second Amendment rights and that's why
when when they proposed this stuff and
people think it's crazy you should
always listen very carefully to what the
left is telling you because they mean it
exactly and I've spent you know 48 years
not becoming a conspiracy minded not a
tinfoil hat guy but I have to say I
noticed that the same people who are
pushing for social control using
financial instruments like credit cards
are the same ones calling for a cashless
society where you they'll be no more
currency and you'll be dependent upon
credit cards no and we're actually
getting quite a ways towards that I mean
checks are all but useless and and and
so effectively they will be saying well
you can have a MasterCard or you can
have a Visa card but either way you
can't buy a gun with it what
and and that's intentional these things
are not accidental now their forms of
social control mark Stein will join us
in a couple of segments because Hillary
Clinton has claimed that she is the
champion of the women's movement and
mark has been thinking about mark we'll
see in just a minute thank you